I like getting cupcakes.
What's embarrassing
about a cupcake?
I don't know,
'cause I just feel like I'm-
The word. The cupcake guy.
It's the word.
And,you know, and I can't be
with my boys be like,
"What do you guys wanna do?"
They be like, "Oh, beer,
strippers." I'm like,
"What about cupcakes? Anybody?"
It's the way you say cupcakes.
Are you a cupcake guy?
Hell yeah bro.
Absolutely?Ah I'd [bleep]
with a cupcake or two.
Vegan or you go regs?
Reg. Regs you said?
What's up everybody?
Welcome to Stupid Questions.
We're in Los Angeles.
So we got Justin Long.
That's why you got me.
I like your energy so far.
You have very good vibes.
Oh yeah? Absolutely.
Thanks Chris.
I really believe that.
This is a stupid question.
What do you think is something
everybody looks stupid doing?
Selfies. Dumb. A few occasions
I've done it [inaudible]
I always feel like
I'm masturbating or something.
Yeah. I always feel kinda
like embarrassed by it.
And you know what I think
everyone looks stupid doing
and I know we have to.
But the flight attendant who has
to demonstrate the safety rules.
Yes, yes.
You look like such an idiot.
What would you prefer,
that a flight attendant commit
to the whole thing like this,
in a very severe like ...
or sometimes they try
to be funny with it.
Yeah. Which would you prefer?
I always want commitment.
'Cause when you try to be funny
with that it's like stupid.
That's true.
I want you to commit.
I want you to blow up
the inflatable raft.
Why don't you open up this door
and show me how to slide down
'Cause it's also serious
stuff to talk about.
Absolutely.
But you don't need to do this.
Here's a flight attendant.
Sorry, he's my friend.
That guy has full blown
FAF flight attendant face.
You have to pick one.
Boat shoes or khakis?
Boat shoes or khakis pants?
Khaki pants or boat shoes.
Boat shoes are the ones
with no laces?
You know what boat shoes are.
You're from Connecticut.
Am I naked without the pants?
Yeah.
You can be naked with boat shoes
showing off your
Connecticut piece
or you're with khakis
showing off your man feet.
Well I don't wanna walk around
with my stuff outside.
Why not dude? Be proud of it.
You're from Connecticut. Yeah.
Show off that
Connecticut [bleep]
I guess that is a Connecticut
thing, you're right. Yes.
The people in Connecticut really
love to show off their penises.
Why not dude?
Beautiful white dick.
Yeah.
I'm gonna say boat shoes now.
What I wanted the great people
of America to envision,
Justin Long just boat shoes
and that's what we got
and now my mom is probably happy
and horny.Congratulations.
Would you rather be able
to only whisper or only shout?
I'm talking like every time
you say a word,
it's a whisper, it's a shout.
That is a really good question.
I think I'd rather whisper.Well
I feel like L.A.'s
more of a whisper city
and New York's more
of a shout city.
Here's why I think
you might be wrong.
Because there's a lot
of shouting in cars and,
"[bleep] Driver,"
all of that in a car.
But also another thing
I noticed in L.A.
I noticed people being way
to demonstrative and exuberant
when they see one another.Yeah.
Everything's [bleep] mono.
Hey you. Yeah, yeah,yeah.
And like ...
I asked somebody
that I saw embrace this way-
Right. Big hugs.
I mean, they screamed
from across the block.
And I said,
"Just out of curiosity,
how long has it been?"
"Oh, how long has it been
since I've seen you?"
They said,
"About a week I guess."
'Cause they were in ...
Yeah. A week. A week.
First of all, I'm being
dead serious right now.
Huge fan. Thanks dude.
You know what favorite movie.
The Break-Up, when you play-
Yes.
The assistant in
the Break-Up, number one.
I also loved you in Waiting.
But now I like to give you
a stupid gift.
It's a dodge ball 'cause you
were in the movie Dodgeball.
It was a big movie,
blockbuster movie.
People know you from it.
You know, you would be shocked
how many times people
yell stuff like,
"Hey, you wanna see my goat
or you wanna see-
Yeah. Which is a weird thing
to yell. Strangers.
So I did this movie called
Zack and Miri Make A Porno.
Sure. And I had a line in it
where I said,
"You better shut your mouth
or I'm gonna [bleep]"
and TSA guy once said to me,
"No ...
but you better shut your mouth
or I'm gonna [bleep] it."
Wow. Yeah.
In what way is that no [bleep]?
Absolutely dude. That's gotta be
at least a modicum of [bleep]
I agree. Stupid questions,
thank you for playing Justin
Long.
Thanks Chris.
No seriously,
it was great to meet you.
It was really fun.
Thank you yeahNo a little
[bleep] Yeah. A little [bleep]
Absolutely. Actually
Plenty of [bleep].
Yeah.